all right I'm gonna explain the game so
this game welcome to this game it's a
game can we'll explain the game yeah
this game and you know what three one is
about I'm Nadia just know you get a like
sheet
yeah like screen sheet we're all is in
Figure everyone is invisible so we'll
see each other's screens and that's how
we figure out how to look it's gonna
find each other what the [ __ ] that was
them so wacky guys
oh god my screen is so tiny do I have to
use a controller for this yes I saw one
Oh God Oh somebody's out how how does a
total accident
dude already I'm gonna do why I was
testing my goal like wait a shine you
[ __ ] you do that oh you're by that I
saw oh oh it's like that is it
wait who's who come on come at me bro oh
you gotta be I do buy eggs over here
emoji brah
there's a pooter pie where's the pudding
noobtube sucker [ __ ] that oh there's
different what whoa what the bushes what
do you know the Boas over I don't wait
how do we there anywhere i how do i how
do i meth quaint ears okay right scruffy
howdy Rory's be lasted ha ha ha I change
I change weapons before how do I do it
again cuz this is [ __ ] why are you
hiding oh wow then you bad look I have a
chandeliers he can suck my chandelier in
the ass that look
where's I'm gonna chandelier your ass oh
oh no no you don't know what dad forgot
you camper camper what is you [ __ ]
when you leave shut up it's my
chandelier and ain't nobody questioned
it I'm a slap a [ __ ] with it
oh come at me bro
come at me bro yeah camper [ __ ]
camper [ __ ] noob oh my can i reap
Uribe oh hi Jesus wash [ __ ] oh my god
I'm a horse and she what is hoarding
sing oh yeah oh you can see the weapon
can you sell horse Koba I see someone
[ __ ] are you guys how do I kill you oh
it's coming - yeah one kill to
everywhere will pull this breed for gain
salad didn't even get a kill bet you
didn't have many friends in high school
I was the most popular Istria Lee no no
I think I do YouTube why do you think we
all do YouTube do oh wait I'm sticking
with his trihard Ken weapon now so I
will win I knew what to get me you may
kill yourself I just stuck my ass
capping at a corn eight salad delicious
such good salad you know what time it is
I'm only at zero no I should both random
/ oh yes okay it's on oh oh oh oh
Shannon Lee Ross your ass [ __ ]
that's a king oh I need hog that [ __ ] I
got now do you like that Jesus I don't
even know we've been running around
everywhere Wow yeah time baby
MLG 360 Dan don't rattle candy dare you
can't Hills candelabra whoa what's up
candles
what's [ __ ]
crack hate rice no you day
dave-o
360 Emily knows go scope ha ha oh no you
know where people are he's just swinging
his camera or there might accidentally
solid handle sneak you it's all now are
you it what you at bro wait wait on
gentlemen the time of the chandelier
uh no thrive again odors are porters I'm
solid so sheesh it's right above me
oh Ken again Jack thought that's on you
the gray you know what that's on you
jack he and you earlier go suck a little
hmm I'm going where this case my mom
tell me to do it gets it you have to
make fun of me for it Judah alright I'm
gonna I'm gonna win this one just mock
my we're gentlemen its mock your words
mock my though where's my mouth is
what's the candlestick already uh well
written every Zemel Oh shucks my ass
funny Wow
I got robbed coming are you where'd you
go where'd you go hit watch salad
Saturday salad you touch me or something
oh wow Sal and academics press x to
jason it didn't work what the [ __ ] they
like they st. no heavy nation Jason we
should do Marco Polo Marco
vallah [ __ ] Marco salad get away from
me salad Marco where are you Marco Marco
Marco
okay look you just run around spamming
button - dude I know exactly where you
are [ __ ] I 360 MLG noscope you oh geez
shut damn man
I just uninstalled salad but how am I
still playing Oh Oh chef Lee almost
winning oh my i just wheel internet what
we'll have five I don't like this come
on guys can I win one time please I've
been winning so much so if I let you
guys win it makes it even more oh you
think there's like oh now there's no
hope he thinks he's cool but he's
actually a pool
cuz some fool he's at why I fell off the
mat I fell off the map did yes I flew so
much I want to try that way oh [ __ ] I
aimed it all in the sky heat oh [ __ ] no
I was at it I got a double kill why was
that fair by well 13 deaths yes Alan
whatever well you [ __ ] killed six so
whatever and died 12 so technically I'm
better dang i killed myself three times
I'm gonna tweet this so everyone will
know [ __ ] what does this mouse could
give milligrams so sour I could let it
become old [ __ ]